souriant ce soir uefa je saurai mais
c'est dur de se remettre à la fois du
départ du pape et de la mort de stéphane
hessel c'est vrai flash présente sais
pas je veux dire le pape c'est dur pour
une fois qu'on avait un pape un peu
poétique c'est un puceau qui va
expliquer aux africains la sexualité on
l'attend
mais sans plus attendre passons en revue
cette semaine tellement incroyable
passionnante où chacun dans son travail
et d'autres dans leur chômage ont pu
méditer cette phrase de cioran à quoi
bon
politique alors véronique genest se
lance dans l'arène alors la déclarer un
truc formidable
je ne suis ni raciste ni xénophobe je
suis agnostique et la séparation de
l'état et de la religion me va bien
une phrase qui est à peu près autant de
sens que de déclarer je ne suis
allergique ni au gluten ni aux huîtres
je prends dans le cul et l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche 5 ans
[Applaudissements]
cela dit moi je n'ai ce jeu l'envié elle
boit pas et pourtant il alerte tout le
tambour est donc c'est un peu
autre fan de la semaine ségolène royal
qui nous gratifie d'une fulgurance les
femmes sont de meilleurs gestionnaires
que les hommes ben c'est normal elles
gagnent moins donc elles sont obligées
de
ségolène royal qui justifie le truc
voyez-vous frédéric lefebvre il dit
les femmes ont l'habitude de gérer un
budget familial quand je lui rappelle
qu'en général budget familial c'est
juste une autre manière de dire salaire
du mari
donc elle est nommée à la bpi là elle va
faire gestion des finances toi toute
façon c'est sa seule expérience c'est
quoi gérer le poitou charentes ça doit
pas être très compliqué en profilés une
subvention tous les quatre ans au vendée
globe est payé la blanchisserie de
passe-partout à fort boyard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
speak english saprophytes haute
joaillerie une ligne de bijoux style
esclaves a été lancé enfin moi j'étais
extrêmement content mais évidemment ça
fait polémique dans ce pays tout de
suite à ces très mal vu d'être à la fois
soumis écho kae
alors qu'il ya du progrès pour une fois
qu'on propose des bracelets en or donc
quelque chose dipolaire génique c'est à
dire esclaves peut-être mais sans
tétanos
alors c'est sûr bien sûr que
l'esclavagisme ce n'est pas bien c'est
vrai c'est vrai que c'est un vivre
ensemble qui ne laissait que peu de
place au dialogue social entre employés
et patrons
après on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais
eux au moins ils avaient un travail
c'est factuel c'est pas moi c'est les
chiffres
d'où la question vaut-il mieux être
libre et chômeurs ou esclaves est
occupée internationale
chavez est mort vous savez chavez le
mannequin go sports bariolées alors
espèce de kim jong il qui fait la
lambada alors quand même deux ans de
combat contre le cancer et il ne l'a pas
vaincu ça c'est quand même dommage ça
aurait fait un chouette invités de
troisième partie
c'est vrai c'est vrai quand même
l'ironie de l'histoire pour un gauchiste
altermondialiste succombé à un cancer du
côlon
toute façon je me sentais que c'était la
forte quand tu vois un vieux président
se promener en jogging c'est soigner les
malades soit il et fou donc c'était un
peu
alors mercredi paraît qu'en dépit de la
mort de chavez les marchés n'ont pas
plongé
un marché financier qui plonge après la
mort d'un marxiste
c'est tout y'a pas de bague trouvé ça
sympa seconds rôles
arcis très bien
alors le seul talent de chavez aurait
beaucoup de gens qui chouine français
c'est quoi c'est de savoir ouvrir une
pipe à fuel enfin je veux dire que le
venezuela c'est quoi c'est à qatar
laïque chaves et un chèque jobijoba
c'est tout un pompiste avec un treillis
5 étoiles alors j'espère qu'il apprendra
au moins un truc à l'extrême gauche
l'avenir c'est pas les ag branlette dans
un atelier carrosserie mais les gaz de
schiste c'est ça le vrai truc mélenchon
qui chialent parce que chavez est parti
sur un coup on a perdu le soleil de la
cordillère le cher leader de la pompe à
fuel
mélenchon il en est toujours aux années
60 c'est terrible mélenchon on dirait
vraiment un minitel déguisé en macbook
international toujours on a tué des
chefs salafistes au mali
il paraît on n'est pas sûr certains
disent qu'il s'agit d' abou zayed ben le
borne haute de mokhtar belmokhtar en
fait des mondes cocktail tu vois des
trucs
après le bloody mary le mokhtar
belmokhtar own the cailloux enfin bref
c'est tout seul
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement a de bonnes raisons de
penser que les otages français sont
toujours en vie je serai de la famille
de ces otages méfierais parce qu'un
gouvernement qui certifie la vie
d'otages mais qui est incapable
d'authentifier la mort des responsables
à un moment
je m'interrogeais
quand on commence à s'interroger on se
dit que quatre soldats français morts au
mali
comme quoi c'est moins dangereux que la
corse
[Applaudissements]
rubrique femmes pourquoi pas
alors cette semaine encore un sondage on
demande aux français quelle est leur
femme politique préférée deux femmes au
top christine lagarde et marine le pen
la gérante d' agences bancaires et la
guichetière de la police des frontières
alors ça s'explique autant une française
qui a réussi à new york ça impressionne
autant une bretonne qui a échoué chez
les ch'tis s'attendrit
médicale
hollande a réussi avec succès son examen
biologique et médicale alors s'il fait
tout comme mitterrand il a donc un
cancer de la prostate
marisol touraine demande d'une enquête
sur la cigarette électronique c'est vrai
qu'il ya des vrais sujets en france en
ce moment à quand le livre noir du
smecta le rapport annuel sur le talk
au moins je peux déjà donné les
conclusions de l'enquêté la cigarette
électronique est moins nocive qu'une
cigarette normale mais utilisé comme une
pioche qu'elle peut causer la mort
mobilité alors grâce à un nouveau métro
on pourra se déplacer facilement d'une
ville de banlieue à une autre sans
passer par la capitale enfin un geste
pour l'économie parallèle d'un métro qui
relie saint-denis au blanc-mesnil reste
plus qu'à créer une station ratp à
fleury mérogis
economics après la marinière arnaud
montebourg fait la promotion de la
chaussette d'alsace et une photo sur
twitter
depuis sa rupture il brasse
mixeur marinière chaussettes plus que de
redresser la france j'ai l'impression
qu'ils postulent à la redoute quoi
justice une mère de famille condamnée
pour avoir prénommé son fils né un 11
septembre jihad alors il dit que c'est
un non classique c'est vrai ben voyons
c'est un peu comme crucifix chez les
catholiques au nom de chaque couche et
les japonaises fouet
alors de bonnes nouvelles a déjà par
quoi on va finir alors oui hier c'était
la journée de la femme oui on a donc une
année pour l'oublier et s'en remettre
et l'alcool tue 49000 français chaque
année si oublier un peu vite tous les
gens qui ne seraient pas conçu sans lui
oui alors elle est pas belle maman et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux